arrêtons là tu sais ce que je me suis réveillé
ce matin en pensant à une exécution publique que
j'ai fait j'ai vraiment fait mais pour l'instant
je vais me contenter de ce gentil petit qui
va passer en premier alors pendant que tu es sur l'
horloge
ça veut dire vas-y n'est-ce pas  comprends que
c'est le signe universel c'était je n'ai pas
clair pour l'amour du ciel qu'est-ce que tu en as
fait il y a tellement de
symboles universels c'en est un qui n'est évidemment pas
communicable qu'est-ce que
c'est lié
qui le compose qu'est-ce
que c'est sortir pas plus petit d'accord ici je '  j'aime le
dessert
voici j'aimerais le dessert
c'est-à-dire ce serait je ne ferai
plus ça
hey le bateau ne paye pas l'addition ce
serait qui paierait l'addition c'est
où est mon chèque où est mon chèque  s'il
te plait ma joue